allez et alice veulent vendre leur
maison
il signe un contrat de six mois avec le
courtier immobilier
au bout de ces six mois la maison n'est
pas 28 jeux contrat avec le courtier
prend fin un mois plus tard un homme qui
avait visité la maison avec le courtier
contact à l'est et alice le couple
accepte de baisser son prix puisqu'il se
dit qu'ils économisent la commission du
courtier
la vente est conclue quelques semaines
plus tard mais une mauvaise surprise
attend à l'oeil à l'iss le courtier
immobilier leur éclat douze mille
dollars soit la commission prévue à son
contrat en est-il de droit oui dans ce
genre d'entente
une clause prévoit que si la vente a
lieu dans les 180 jours suivant la date
d'expiration du contrat
le vendeur pourrait être obligé de payer
la commission aux courtiers
mais il faut que l'acheteur se soit déjà
intéressé à la maison au moment où le
contrat était en vigueur
cette clause vise à protéger les
courtiers des clients qui aura table
volontairement la vente de leur maison
pour épargner la commission le fin mot
de l'histoire
l'obligation payer une commission aux
courtiers immobiliers ne s'éteint pas
totalement à la fin du contrat